à l'été de venir en territoire et penly
en france sans le consentement des
parents et les arachides leur territoire
pour les amis dans d'autres régions dans
deux provinces très très loin l'objectif
était de tuer il a aidé dans un faux
joint justement 182 tombes anonymes ont
été découvertes sur le site d'un ancien
pensionnat à cranbrook en colombie
britannique
et c'est la troisième découverte de ce
type en un mois on parle ici de génocide
de politique génocidaire ça va au delà
de la culture mais plutôt un crime
contre
l'humanité obsède une nation
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins et
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mardi 28 septembre
la france n'aura pas son propre vaccin
anti qu'ovide arn messagers sanofi jette
l'épongé arguant de son sérum arriverait
trop tard sur le marché le deuxième
abandon en neuf mois dans l'hexagone
après pasteur en janvier des échecs à
répétition dont qui interroge sur l'état
de la recherche française elle sans
signal d'alarmé important la france seul
pays membre permanent du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu à ne pas avoir
développé avec 5 contres locaux vides
commercialisée à grande échelle
paris réduit de moitié les visas
accordés l algérie au maroc un tiers
pour la tunisie décision prise suite à
des difficultés rencontrées par la
france pour renvoyer dans leur pays du
maghreb leurs ressortissants en
situation irrégulière la gestion
migratoire sujets favoris de plusieurs
candidats à la présidentielle à sept
mois du scrutin à commencer par marine
le pen qui en a détaillé cet après midi
son projet de référendum sur
l'immigration réactions depuis tunis et
analyses à suivre dans cette émission
au sommaire à 21h un autre thème phare
de la campagne présidentielle le pouvoir
d'achat des français les prix de
l'énergie ont flambé ces derniers mois
et ce n'est pas fini dont trois jours
les tarifs réglementés du gaz
augmenteront de 12,6 pour cent en
moyenne la facture d'électricité
salez pourrait aussi grimper en 2022
pour certains politiques ces hausses à
venir sont une véritable bombe sociale à
retardement
alors sommes nous à l'aube d'une
nouvelle mobilisation à l'instar des
gilet jaune quel dispositif dead sont
sur la table du gouvernement
le débat est ouvert
il y à des retards qui ne se rattrape
jamais sanofi renonce donc à développer
la phase 3 des essais de son vaccin arn
messagers contre le commis 19 annonce
faite par le laboratoire français ce
matin on retrouve estelle farges devant
le siège du groupe pharmaceutique
bonsoir estelle qu'est ce qui explique
cette décision
et bien parce qu'il n'ya pas de besoins
de santé publique d'avoir un autre
vaccin arn messagers c'est en tout cas
ce qu'a estimé le vice président de la
branche vaccins du groupe sanofi le
laboratoire français considère tout
simplement que son vaccin arriverait
trop tard sur le marché et pour cause 12
milliards de doses de vaccin anti kovy
19 auront été produites et d'ici à la
fin de l'année objectif donc pour sanofi
équipe et la france et l'europe d'un
arsenal de vaccins à arn messagers pour
une prochaine pandémie ou une prochaine
pathologie une vision a tout de même
nuancé par l' oms qui indique qu auprès
de nos confrères de la fp avoir besoin
d'autant de vaccins de qualité que
possible pour pouvoir vacciner la
planète contre le coc vite 19 estelle
sanofi qui souhaitent tout de même un se
positionner sur la technologie arn
messager
mais exactement carey sanofi est un
groupe pharmaceutique spécialisée dans
les vaccins et la rn messager est une
opportunité à ne pas louper le
laboratoire souhaite donc se positionner
sur cette technologie notre objectif est
de libérer le potentiel de la rn
messager dans d'autres domaines
stratégiques comme par exemple
l'immunologie ou l'oncologie c'est en
tout cas est ce qu avait précisé il ya
déjà plusieurs semaines le directeur
général de sanofi chaleur en parallèle
le groupe travaille avec le laboratoire
britannique gsk sur un autre vaccin
contre le coc vie 19 il s'agit d'un
rappel à injecter aux personnes qui
présentent un schéma vaccinal au complet
peu importe le sérum utilisé parmi
moderna pfizer ou encore johnson and
johnson elle les résultats de l'essai
clinique de la phase iii sont d'ailleurs
attendus d'ici à la fin de l'année merci
estelle farges un an et demi donc après
le début de la pandémie de cauvigny de
la france n'a donc toujours pas réussi à
produire son propre vaccin que dit cet
échec la recherche française est elle à
bout de souffle argent investi est il
utilisé à bon escient débat avec un nos
invités c'est l'heure du face à face
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
gérard filoche porte parole de la gauche
démocratique et sociale bonsoir gérard
filoche à vos côtés jean marc flipo
porte-parole de debout la france bonsoir
jean marc gibeau merci d'être avec nous
alors donc après pasteur on le disait en
janvier sanofi maintenant clairement la
france est le seul pays des membres du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qui n'a pas
son propre vaccin est ce qu'on peut
parler jean marc flipo d'échec
industriels
je sais pas si c'est un échec industriel
comme le disait très justement votre
votre reporter il ya des retards qui ne
se rattrape pas en l'occurrence c'était
effectivement trop tard mais moi ce que
je constate surtout c'est que les
objectifs de santé publique qui étaient
dévolues à ces laboratoires dans le par
le passé aujourd'hui s'efface devant
deux des logiques de marc de marché
stricto sensu je pense qu'effectivement
le le docteur adams gebreyesus qui est
directeur général de l' oms a dû tomber
de sa chaise lorsqu'il a entendu qu'il
n'y avait pas de besoins de santé
publique pour un vaccin arn messagers
alors on peut discuter de comment dire
de des effets secondaires de la rn
messager delà du temps nécessaire pour
en mesurer toutes les conséquences
m'enfin y'a quand même toute l'afrique
qui n'est pas mesurée qui n'est pas
vacciné pardon et est en mesure pas
encore les conséquences de cette absence
de vaccination sur ce continent voilà
donc c'est vraiment on est dans une
logique purement de marché
effectivement sanofi avec gsk développe
un vaccin
traditionnelle et ils vont rapporter les
marchés f1 ils vont se positionner sur
un marché de la troisième dose qui est
tout simplement gigantesque puisque aux
états unis on ne parle que de ça il sera
elle ne parle que de ça et j'ai pu mais
le pari qu'en france on en parlera avec
insistance très bientôt donc là ils vont
remporter à forme de jackpot et puis ils
vont rapporter aussi le jackpot sur leur
développement parce qu'ils ont fait des
travaux quand même sur la rn messager et
essayent ils sont en train de le
réorienter vers la grippe saisonnière
puisqu'ils ont commencé les essais de
phase 1 donc en juin dernier qui sont
apparemment prometteur et la
problématique de la grippe saisonnière
c'est que le virus change tous les ans
et qui est donc un teint d'adaptabilité
assez long entre le moment où on
développe le virus très bleu vaccins
traditionnels et le moment où on livre
les les doses et si on arrive à
raccourcir ce qu'on arrive à raccourcir
ce délai eh bien ce sera plus efficace
et on pourra donc livré un vaccin
beaucoup plus efficace et ça c'est un
immense marché à l'échelle planétaire
avant de donner la parole à gérard
filoche je vous propose d'écouter l'une
des réactions politiques un nombreuses
évidemment depuis ce matin celle
d'esther benbassa sénatrice écologiste
paris
sanofi toujours en avance faire de la
recherche ou faire du fric parfois il
faut choisir le laboratoire français
arrêtent le développement de son vaccin
à arn messagers effectivement dans la
lignée de ce que vous venez de nous dire
un jean-marc chipeau alors c'est vrai
qu'on recontextualise tout d'abord
gérard filoche assure le diagnostic et
cet art est un petit peu stratégique
puisque sanofi dit bien voilà ça servira
à rien on sera trop nombreux sur le
marché autant se concentrer sur le le
rappel et avancer sur sur d'autres
secteurs sur le diagnostic qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
ce n'est pas une question de la
nationalité du vaccin c'est une question
de la cupidité les actionnaires
l'actionnariat visiblement de sanofi est
plus intéressé par l'ampleur de ses
profits maximum que par l'intérêt
général des humains c'est ça la question
fondamentale rappelez vous il ya même
pas combien le 6 mois ils ont supprimé
400 postes 4 santos dans les domaines de
recherche et développement rappelez-vous
la photo de philippe martinez devant
sanofi les manifestations des salariés
on est dans un pays où l'habitude de ne
pas écouter les salariés mais en un pays
où il n'y a pas l'habitude d'écouter les
syndicats eh ben les syndicats et les
salariés avaient raison et en
l'occurrence il dénonçait davance ce qui
dit des les actionnaires je répète c'est
la cupidité pas l'intérêt général et
donc ça pose toute la question de la
recherche en france des moyens encore
souvenir d'un témoignage de bruno canard
qui était un chercheur du cnrs du cnrs à
marseille et il expliquait la science ne
marche pas dans l'urgence et la réponse
immédiate dès 2008 2009 en france il
travaillait son corps n'avait russe est
depuis à la fois sarkozy hollande et
marron qui sont pas des gens qu'on fait
que se sont opposés à la finance ils ont
coupé les crédits les moyens de
rechercher pour la la recherche publique
et la recherche publique a été en mise à
bas également par la loi de
programmation de la recherche je me
souviens j'étais encore il ya un an en
novembre 2020 dans une lara semble un
rassemblement à l'université de censier
où il y avait des centaines des milliers
de gens qui disaient attention va dans
le mur pourquoi ma chronique ou t-il pas
ce qu'ils savent il croit tout savoir
sur la loi de programmation de la
recherche il s'est trompé de a à z la
recherche publique et
ses crédits les ont eues en sanofi mais
peut-être certainement vous allez nous
dire puisque ça va être obligé notre
débat on va continuer à poursuivre
évidemment sur sur les causes et mais
justement sanofi a bénéficié et c'est
bien l'objet des critiques je vais vous
redonner la parole vous inquiétez pas
150 millions d'euros sous forme
justement de crédit impôt recherche ou
sous la forme du cic am fameux crédit
impôt compétitivité emploi
clairement jean-marc chypre va redonner
la parole à gérard filoche évidemment
qui trépigne sur ce thème c'est de
l'argent mal investi ou investit trop
tard
c'est un vin qui est investi accord
peut-être à contre temps je sais pas
peut-être trop tard mais c'est surtout
un partenariat quelque chose qui s'est
cassé dans le dans l'articulation de la
recherche française lorsque l'épidémie
coronavirus est arrivé donald trump aux
états unis a développé a lancé une
opération de cirque et war speed et
cette opération a porté sur 11 millions
de dollars sa femme après 1,9 milliard
et demi d'euros pour l'ensemble de
l'union européenne en avait que deux
milliards d'euros qui était qui étaient
débloqués donc on voit bien déjà il ya
un immense décalage on enterre de
entière de volume d'argent investies
ensuite comme le disait monsieur filoche
et je vais vous surprendre je suis
d'accord avec lui la recherche la
recherche médicale et s'effectue comme
la recherche d'ailleurs sur le temps
long et effectivement le
l'état a le devoir de a traversé le
notamment cnrs bas de lancer des
recherches
sur des maladies en plus de celles qui
ne sont pas rentables parce qu'une
recherche serait maladie qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas rentable on le voit les peu
coronavirus là ça peut devenir très
rentable dès maintenant qu'il ya de
nouveaux partenariats à renouer on va
parvenir à la recherche et à tiques
gaullienne des années 60 il en a basculé
dans un autre monde un monde vraiment
l'argent est roi où les marchés
commandes mais par contre il faut remuer
des partenariats et surtout avoir des
retours sur investissement lorsque
l'état investit faut qu ils de retour
sur investissement le crédit impôt
recherche c'est très bien mais en france
en arts n'a l'habitude d'empêcher les
gens au départ lent des créations de
biotech par exemple on les empêche de
deux recherchés on leur met des charges
un peu partout sur les épaules et puis
après on leur met des des béquilles pour
pour développer la recherche dans le
crédit impôt recherche c'est ça les
start up française les biotech française
les medtechs françaises qui sont qui
sont innovantes qui sont qui sont
nombreuses ont besoin d'avoir d'avoir un
accès à la recherche fondamentale et
atic ont besoin d'avoir un archet un
accès aux financements
c'est vraiment par là qu'on pêche
développer une molécule ses 10 ans
travaille et c'est environ un milliard
d'euros donc il faut ré accompagner nos
pépites françaises il faut ensuite
empêcher qu'elle ne tombe effectivement
sous la coupe d'entreprises
principalement américaines qui font de
la prédation scientifique effectivement
gérard filoche on imagine que vous êtes
d'accord avec jean marc chipeau c'est
quelque chose qu'on a vu tout au long de
cette pandémie dès les petites
entreprises qui n'étaient pas
subventionner toujours et soutenu
suffisamment par l'état et qui trouvait
les subventions souvent ailleurs à
l'étranger notamment du royaume uni
voire des états unis
et même j'étais en train de vous le dire
sous sarkozy y crée bien pour rechercher
passé de 1.5 milliard 6 milliards soit
deux fois le budget du cnrs c'est à dire
que la recherche publique a été spolié
au bénéfice de la recherche privée et la
recherche privée elle n'agit pas sur le
long terme elle n'agit pas selon
l'intérêt général elle agit selon des
marges de profits et les décisions des
actionnaires c'est pour ça qu'il faut
donner la priorité à la recherche
publique qu'il faut donner l'argent pour
le temps long qu'il faut donner l'argent
à ceux qui sont préoccupés l'intérêt
général et qu'il faut pas le donner aux
cupids actionnaires qui dirige sanofi et
qui supprime des emplois pour augmenter
leurs marges bénéficiaires
c'est aussi simple que ça ce à quoi nous
assistons et quand je disais c'est la
croûte à macron ce n'est pas à lui
seulement puisque avant sarkozy et
hollande n'ont pas privilégier la
recherche publique puisque la mode est à
donner au privé aux start up au lieu de
donner à la recherche d'eau font et à
tous les services qui vont avec c'est
quand même un choix fondamental macron
dans ses choix budgétaires
il se rattrape jamais les erreurs non
plus quand on enlève la recherche
publique quand on enlève aux hôpitaux
quand on enlève à sécurité sociale quand
on enlève aux services publics dans leur
ensemble et bien en hérésie runes tarots
si dérisoire
là on a mis la relance chez sanofi eh
bien ça vous classe dans les doigts et
bien là on a mis l'argent c'est sanofi
bien ne font pas ce qui se fait dans
d'autres pays ce qui fonde d'ailleurs
que mâcon est pire que les dirigeants
capitalistes des autres pays non ses
choix et dans ses investissements et
qu'il a aggravé sa depuis qu'il est là
puisque même en cours d'année là il
vient de d'appuyer la diminution de
crédit de publication et et là je
gardais des syndicalistes qui vous le
dis tous les jours de façon plus
compétente deux mois et qui n'accepte
pas et comme ce pouvoir n'entend rien
des corps intermédiaires des salariés
des syndicats de ceux qui sont publiques
et bien à chaque fois il fait la même
erreur et on a un journal télévisé comme
ce soir madame où on vous dira alors
qu'est ce qui se passe avec sanofi c'est
un échec français mais ya pas de
surprises à nous le savions nous
l'avions dit fallait nous entende faut
changer le gouvernement pourrait que ce
soit des gens qui vous l'ont dit attends
qui gouvernent et qui puissent planifier
maintenant là en tout cas ça donne et
certaines idées notamment à emilie
carillon à la députée
les nouveaux démocrates de la meuse qui
propose justement de se servir du fameux
c'est hier pour favoriser la
relocalisation écouter
cet amendement j'aurais pu la paix
l'amendement sanofi conditionner le
crédit impôt recherche à la
relocalisation des chaînes de production
balayé sanofi continue à toucher et le
crédit d'impôt recherche abandonne la
recherche sur le vaccin est reine stop à
l'argent public déversés sans
contrepartie
jean marc flipo c'est un début de piste
conditionné justement à la
relocalisation
écoutez moi je suis ravi que toute la
france se convertissent au aux idées de
nicolas dupont aignan est debout la
france nous n'avons eu de cesse de
répéter cela depuis au moins depuis 2012
c'est merveilleux là je trouve que
nicolas dupont aignan se présente à la
présidentielle et que dans son programme
effectivement
indiqué mme qui concerne la
relocalisation de la production des
principes actifs et des médicaments et
que pour accéder à remboursement par la
sécurité sociale parce que ce sont les
français qui payent il ya l'aspect
financement de la recherche mais après
vous avez les français qui doivent payer
les médicaments qui doivent payer les
vaccins via leurs cotisations sociales
eh bien on veut conditionner
effectivement le remboursement de ces ma
gueule de ces médicaments et ses
principes actifs à la production sur le
sol national à hauteur de 50% au moins
pour les pour les médicaments qui ont un
déremboursement supérieur à 20 millions
d'euros et ça effectivement
c'est quelque chose de concret qui peut
faire changer qu'il va faire changer les
mentalités gfi d'achat sur wii allez-y
joan olivé réalise notamment
oui si vous venez de sa réduire le
problème comme ça moi aussi je suis
candidat à la présidentielle par un émoi
à la primaire populaire et je vous dirai
des choses bien plus complète que ce que
vous venez de dire parce que moi je
m'appuie sur les salariés les syndicats
et ce qui attend publiquement ont milité
manifester fait grève pour que ce que
nous voyons ce soir n'arrive pas et je
vous ai pas beaucoup vu ni dans les
grèves les manifestations ni dans l'art
soldats étaient les salariés vous ai pas
beaucoup vu attends défendre le public
contre le privé j'ai plutôt linfort
l'intérêt que l'impasse l'idée que vous
faites le contraire alors si vous
réduisez une autre débat ce soir à une
candidature vous jure que seraient
meilleures en défense des salariés que
votre dupont aignan je vous jure que je
serais beaucoup plus attentifs au
service public et à l'ensemble de la
recherche publique parce que moi les
choix que je veux faire stratégiquement
sont évidemment très différents des
vôtres et de tous ceux qui défendent le
capitalisme sous une forme nationale ou
pas et donc je suis moi pour la priorité
aux salariés pour les écouter les
entendit saab ils ont des comités ils
ont des syndicats et ils ont eu raison
plus lucidement que les dirigeants de
sanofi plus lucidement que les
actionnaires de sanofi est donc
maintenant faut faire des choix stop à
l'argent et à la cupidité oui au service
public oui à la défense de l'intérêt des
humains oui internet à l'écouté des
salariés et si vous m'avez amenée à dire
ça c'est parce que c'est finalement
quelque part la question essentielle
pour que se débarrasser de macron
aujourd'hui il a failli en tout on avait
pas de gel on n'avait pas de mal si on
n'avait pas de lit on n'avait pas de
cinq années
on a cité des anges on te pose et on a
bien compris le médecin vous rêvez
répété plusieurs fois on a compris voilà
c'était le service public avant tout
mais ce que nous disait jean marc flipo
tout à l'heure donald trump qui investit
des milliards c'était une vraie force de
guerre il est rentré en guerre contre ce
virus il a investi des milliards le
vaccin est sorti en novembre
annonçait d'ailleurs au lendemain de la
présidentielle et la victoire de joe
biden pourtant on vous n'êtes pas un
grand défenseur du libéralisme façon
trump et ça a marché là bas quelle
différence avec la france
soulevés en france le salaire moyen des
chercheurs et 63 % du salaire de l' ocde
sur dix en france ils ont adopté un
système qui est tellement controversé
parce qu'il est pas par projet donc il
est il est pas une recherche générale
fondamental c'est un système qui est
orientée sur le produit sur un point
donné et donc la france souffre des
choix gouvernementaux qui ont été faits
et je vous répète que c'est intimement
liés la politique gouvernementale
et donc voilà qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise de plus la france
entière selon le perçoit aujourd'hui
quand on vous dit a pas de vaccin
français c'est pas le problème du bac ça
c'est le problème du capitalisme et de
ceux qui en france se soumettre aux
discours desiderata internationaux des
trusts pharmaceutiques dont sanofi jean
marc flipo le salaire des des chercheurs
ça aussi l'inde est l'une des clés du
problème aujourd'hui et de cet échec
oui bien évidemment il ya un énorme
problème
sur le salaire des chercheurs sur le
salaire des universités enfin ya tout un
tas tout un chantier enfin sur certains
points je veux pas je peux faire adhérer
le fil au chat debout la france mais je
pense qu'un certain nombre de points sur
lesquels on peut effectivement se
rejoindre mais si vous voulez
au delà de ça c'est tout c'est tout
l'articulation vraiment entre la
recherche publique fondamentale temps
long effectivement la recherche la
recherche fondamentale c'est quoi c'est
rechercher en médecine par exemple des
molécules dont on ne sait pas s'ils
auront un jour une utilité et ça il n'ya
pas effectivement il ya très peu
d'entreprises privées qui le font ou
alors elles délèguent ça maintenant
adebiotech quelle qu'elles vont absorber
tout de suite en site tout de suite
derrière pour faire du profit mais on a
besoin aujourd'hui le monde et est
confronté à de plus en plus de vagues
épidémiques y aller il ya pas mal de
danger qui guette la planète on a besoin
effectivement de rebâtir un pôle de
recherche fondamentale en france et qui
va tirer ensuite l'industrie derrière et
qui va nous permettre mais aussi d'avoir
demain des vaccins sur dos contre
d'autres maladies la lutte contre le
cancer et pense à ça et est un enjeu
mondial fondamentale on a besoin de
vraiment se se mobiliser là dessus si
beaucoup attendait d'eux jean marc flipo
gérard filoche d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france
les conséquences de la pandémie à
l'échelle mondiale le qu'ovide 19 qui a
considérablement fait baisser
d'espérance de vie en 2020 c'est la
conclusion d'une étude réalisée dans 29
pays développés les explications en
images avec juliette lamy
une étude réalisée par des chercheurs
britanniques allemands et danois dans 29
pays développés dont 27 en europe
montrent que la pandémie a fait chuter
l'espérance de vie en 2020 à des niveaux
jamais observés depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale
les états unis payent le plus lourd
tribut avec une baisse de 2,2 ans
d'espérance de vie à la naissance chez
les hommes et 1,6 en chez les femmes
[Musique]
au total les chercheurs ont enregistré
une chute supérieure à un an de
l'espérance de vie dans 11 pays pour les
hommes et dans huit pays pour les femmes
il avait fallu en moyenne cinq des six
années à seppi pour gagner un ans
d'espérance de vie il a été effacé d'un
trait en 2020 par le co lead les plus
durement frappées après les américains
sont la lituanie la bulgarie la pologne
l'espagne le chili
l'italie ainsi que la belgique
six pays d'europe du nord ainsi que la
grèce apparaissent plus épargnés selon
les chercheurs de l'étude la norvège et
le danemark sont les deux seuls pays a
enregistré une augmentation de
l'espérance de vie entre 2019 et 2020
dans tous les pays ce sont les hommes
qui subissent la baisse la plus
importante en europe les personnes âgées
de plus de 60 ans contribuent le plus à
cette chute pour les femmes ce sont même
les octogénaires qui pèse le plus lourd
d'après les chercheurs l'espérance de
vie pourrait dégringoler davantage cette
année cette baisse pourrait résulter de
la population non vaccinée début 2000 21
déc ovide long des retards de soins ou
encore des effets sanitaires de la crise
économique provoquée par la pandémie et
la russie qui doit faire face à une
nouvelle flambée de 4 qu'ovide en cause
le variant delta plus contagieuse c'est
surtout moscou qui est touché mais pas
seulement un rebond que l'on explique
notamment par une vaccination difficile
à mettre en place pour en parler on
retrouve notre correspondant antoine
claireaux à moscou bonsoir antoine la
russie qui vient donc d'atteindre
malheureusement encore une fois un
nouveau record de mortalité quotidienne
oui tout à fait stéphanie en ce mardi la
russie a enregistré un nouveau record de
décès quotidiens duo kobe de 10 9 854
personnes sont mortes ces dernières 24
heures le précédent record qui s'est
élevé à 828 décès remonte à seulement il
ya quelques jours c'était le 24
septembre dernier vaccination quand elle
vous l'avez évoqué continue de piétiner
à l'heure actuelle un peu moins de 30%
de la population russe est entièrement
vacciner les autorités sanitaires en
conviennent seule une couverture
vaccinale de la population plus
importante pourrait enrayer cette
spirale écoutez
parmi la population russe adultes 47
millions ont reçu une dose c'est moins
de la moitié ce n'est pas 60% ce n'est
pas 80% donc pour le moment rien ne
laisse à penser que tout cela va cesser
beaucoup de gens en contact avec le
virus vont encore tomber malade
et malgré cette nouvelle flambée
épidémique est bien les autorités russes
assurent qu'aucune restriction aucun
confinement n'est prévue pour le moment
antoine vous êtes donc à moscou il
disait à quoi ressemble
la vie quotidienne est ce qu'il existe
malgré tout des mesures mises en place
par les autorités
oui bien dans la capitale russe à
l'exception de certains événements il
n'existe pas de passer ni terre aucun
passe sanitaire n'est en vigueur seuls
le port du masque est obligatoire dans
les transports en publics ou encore dans
les lieux fermés qui accueillent du
public comme les restaurants les centres
commerciaux ou encore les magasins par
contre c'était pas forcément le cas
ailleurs en russie en effet chaque
région gère cette problématique en
fonction de sa propre situation
sanitaire dans la ville de perm dans la
chaîne de l'oural dans l'est du pays
enfin à l'est de moscou et bien par
exemple dans cette ville là pour aller
au restaurant il faut présenter un qr
code une preuve de vaccination ou bien
un test pcr négatif merci beaucoup
antoine gayraud en direct de moscou
l'actualité en france avec la course à
la présidentielle est un thème qui
semble omniprésent à la proche du
scrutin celui de l'immigration le sujet
de prédilection du rassemblement
national la candidate du parti marine le
pen a d'ailleurs dévoilé cet après midi
sa proposition d'inscrire dans la
constitution par un référendum la
maîtrise de l'immigration
hasard du calendrier ou non le
gouvernement mais kron a lui annoncé un
peu plus tôt la réduction façon
drastique du nombre de visas accordés
aux citoyens de l'algérie du maroc et de
la tunisie une matière une manière de
sanctionner ces pays qui refusent
d'accueillir leurs ressortissants en
situation irrégulière en france c'est ce
qui a expliqué le porte parole de
l'exécutif gabriela talent et détaillé
en bref et en images
[Musique]
c'est une décision drastique et inédite
mais rendue nécessaire par le fait que
ces pays n'acceptent pas de reprendre
des ressortissants que nous ne pouvons
pas garder en france en 2018 nous avons
adopté la loi asile et immigration et le
frein à cette efficacité et or conduite
effective c'est le fait que des pays
refusent les laissez passer consulaires
à partir de là on a eu un dialogue avec
certains pays du maghreb puis des
menaces et aujourd'hui on met ses
menaces à exécution
[Musique]
on
une réduction du nombre de visas
octroyés par la france qui fait réagir
de nombreux députés si la droite
applaudit cette démarche la gauche elle
sans surprise la condamne
la france à raison elle a raison tout
simplement de mettre des règles dans
l'obtention de ces visas et de les
restreindre avec les pays concernés je
dis simplement que c'est bien tard et
comme ça a l'air facile à six mois de
l'élection présidentielle de prendre des
décisions qui était impossible jusque là
manuel macron est en campagne électorale
mais j'aimerais qu'ils étaient en action
depuis 2010 est si les enfants à l'école
en france y décroche et qui sont plus
compétitifs et qu'on voit notre pays
reculé c'est quoi c'est l'immigration si
on a un problème de logement c'est
l'immigration si on apprend même de
pollution c'est l'immigration c'est à
dire une lubie une phobie une obsession
ça ne fait pas un projet politique et ça
fait pas un candidat à la présidentielle
voilà à l'extrême droite isation
d'insultés ça suffit on va peut-être
parler des deux ce qui concerne vraiment
la vie des gens pouvoir d'achat la
question du blocage des prix la question
environnementale la question du partage
des richesses
tous les sondages vous regardez c'est ce
qui est prioritaire et non pas la
question de l'immigration mais mon
manifestement il ya certains à droite au
gouvernement juge l'averse j'espère que
les élections lors de l'ontt et côté
marocain les réactions n'ont pas tardé
le chef de la diplomatie nasser bourita
à prend acte de cette décision qu'il
considère comme injustifiée et citoyens
marocains aussi déplore cette mesure de
paris
il faut pas voir le mal dans sa décision
donc moi je pense que c'est quelque
chose de très bénéfique
à moyen et à long terme à court terme
parce qu'on va avoir beaucoup
d'étudiants qui veulent aller faire
leurs études en france qui ont fait la
mission ici et on va leur refuser le
visa les marocains ont été surpris ce
matin par cette décision du ministère
des affaires étrangères français nous
considérons au maroc que cette décision
est une répression contre les marocains
et contre la liberté de voyager de
mouvements comme annoncé dans les
conventions internationales et les
accords de voyage et d'itinérance entre
les pays
c'est une décision inattendue prise par
la france contre le maroc la tunisie et
l'algérie et c'est un moyen de pression
car le maroc ne reçoit pas les immigrés
illégaux en france la france ne doit pas
oublier qu'il ya plusieurs étudiants qui
partent chaque année en france pour
terminer leurs études des touristes
marocains aussi
et pour en parler nous sommes avec hatem
nafti essayiste auteur de la révolution
à la restauration où va la tunisie aux
éditions riveneuve bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
sur ce plateau alors avec l'annoncé de
ce gouvernement c'est un véritable coup
de pression sur le maghreb ou pour vous
une opération plutôt de de communication
pour faire de l'ombre peut-être à
l'extrême droite à sept mois de la
présidentielle
quelle est votre vision je pense que
c'est plutôt une décision une décision
électoraliste les gens ne sont pas dupes
on est à quelques mois de la
présidentielle
on a des rup sion
d'un acteur qui d'eric zemmour pour le
palais ni pour ne pas le citer pour le
panneau mais qui qui monomaniaque sur 7
sur cette question qui parle tout le
temps de voilà d'immigration d'islam
d'immigration dise la
marine le pen qui est obligé de suivre
il a regardé toute la planète toute la
classe politique qui s'est mis à la
droite de toute cette classe politique
hors du coup en force en tout cas du
centre gauche même du printemps
républicains jusqu'à l'extrême droite de
il a forcé
toute cette partie du spectre politique
à le suivre donc c'est clairement
quelque chose de politiciens d'autant
qu'
il ya un chiffre qui est pas mal circulé
aujourd'hui qui est le taux de
reconduite aux frontières des fins d
exécution des obligations de quitter le
territoire français qui a circulé qui
est de 0 2% pour les algériens
je pense que ça fait partie de la
stratégie gouvernementale
il faut juste rappeler que l'algérie a
fermé ses frontières se tolèrent ne
concerne que la période entre entre juin
et juillet et précisément sur toute
cette période avait pas de liaisons
aériennes quasiment pas de liaisons
aériennes entre paris et alger par
exemple donc c'est généralement sur des
vols commerciaux qu'ont
qu'on exécute les renvoie les
envois la frontière donc là on est plus
sûr du
du symbolique est
aussi quelque chose qui sent pas très
bon le choix des choix des trois pays
maghrébins c'est voilà on va vous
débarrasser des arabes si vous permettez
l'expression c'est aussi comme ça que
c'est compris il yad'autres ya d'autres
nationalités qui sont qui sont concernés
par les problèmes de migration on
focalise on va là on donne des gages à
son électorat pour leur dire voilà on va
pas exécuter sa et surtout on ne voit
pas dans quel on n'a pas spécifié en
tout cas comment cette décision va être
exécuté il sera intéressant de voir si
ça va concerner que ça concerne l'aspect
volume étudiants il ya du maurice les
travailleurs qualifiés est ce qu'on doit
se passer des travailleurs qualifiés je
ne le pense pas c'est on va continuer
dans ce rapport de force entre le nord
et le sud pour rappel on est dans une
relation totalement asymétrique que un
citoyen français et n'a pas du tout
besoin d'eux voilà autant de démarches
pour aller s'installer où il veut et
voilà c'est une entrave à la liberté de
la circulation et qui opère dans un seul
sens il serait vraiment intéressant de
voir comment on va appliquer ça qui est
ce qu'on va en voir est-ce qu'on va
limiter le regroupement familial si on
voit ça c'est interdire de recevoir des
étudiants ce sera intéressant de voir
comment on aussi ça peut être tout
simplement de l'affichage alors le
gouvernement en tout cas parle lui d'une
décision inédite et il dit qu'il dure
s'il tombe parce que c'est une sorte de
réponse parce que dit il ces pays du
maghreb ne reprendrait pas leurs
ressortissants expulsés
est-ce que ça c'est un argument vous
entendez aussi d'ailleurs pourquoi ces
pays du maghreb ne reprennent pas les
les expulser en france est-ce que ça
calmerait le jeu peut-être
justement et qui est un geste aussi de
ces pays là alors juste avant de venir
j'ai consulté un rapport parlementaire
donc qui chantent d'une instance
étatique qui date de 2010 vite parce que
encore une fois il ne sert à rien de
faire des comparaisons avec 2020 et 2021
on était encore vide donc ce n'est pas
intéressant
alors certes ces trois pays sont
un nombre important de leurs concitoyens
qui se voient délivrer des obligations
de quitter le territoire français le
taux d'exécution est au tour entre 43%
pour la tunisie est à peu près 50% pour
l'algérie et le maroc on voit que la
réduction concerne la verse donc les
tunisiens sont moins pénalisé que les
deux autres que les deux autres
nationalités mais il ya d'autres pays
qui ont des taux similaires par exemple
l'egypte a aussi un taux d'exécution d'à
peu près la moitié et l'egypte récupère
justement non mais elle récupère le taux
d'exécution j'entends par là les
citoyens qui sont effectivement
éloignées du territoire donc est à peu
près le même taux entre l'egypte
l'algérie le maroc je note aujourd'hui
que
qu'on va sanctionner les pays maghrébins
et pas les pays d'egypte siens et je
pense que derrière il ya aussi un enjeu
géopolitique les relations tendues entre
alger et paris bon ça veut dire c'est un
classique il ya eu la sphère pegasus
avec le maroc est sans doute ce qui se
passe en tunisie
motive aussi ceux qui cette décision
gouvernementale
je ne pense pas que ce soit juste le
critère de reconduite ou non à la
frontière ce qu'encore une fois il ya
d'autres pays qui sont à ces niveaux-là
d'exécution des oqtf et qui n'ont pas
été sanctionnées donc pour vous pas
forcément le fond du problème cet
argument brandi par le gouvernement il y
a un aspect électorale mais aussi peut
être une excuse c'est ça selon vous pour
moi il ya deux choses l'aspect électoral
il est clair et net encore une fois
personne n'est dupe et il ya comme
partout à chaque fois qu'il s'agit de
détenus de diplomates il ya des rapports
de force à naître aujourd'hui la france
n'est pas au beau fixe avec ces trois
pays et
elle préfère voilà m 7 cette menace à
exécution mettre la pression certes sur
ces pays là encore une fois on est dans
un rapport qui est totalement
dissymétrique est épargné d'autres pays
je prends juste le cas de l'egypte ce
n'est pas du tout le seul qui
qui expulse enfin dont on expulse à peu
près 20 qui acceptent de récupérer à peu
près la moitié de ses concitoyens qui se
sont vu
signifier une obligation de quitter le
territoire français aujourd'hui
clairement la france peut-elle se
permettre une potentielle crise
diplomatique avec ces trois pays alors
que vous venez de le préciser les
relations sont pas vraiment au beau fixe
oui tout à fait on est encore enfant né
dans la diplomatie on a vu pour prendre
un tout autre exemple on a vu un
problème beaucoup plus important qui est
là faire des sous marins on a vu comment
la france est rentrée dans le rang au
bout d'une semaine et pour autant le
problème n'a pas été résolu en tout cas
au bénéfice de la france quand enfin en
matière de diplomatie c'est toujours les
rapports de force qui prime aujourd'hui
paris s'estime en voilà en position de
force pour imposer ses règles ses trois
anciennes colonies merci beaucoup à
thème la fille d'avoir été avec nous
nous avoir apporté votre point de vue ce
soir merci à vous
pour l'instant pas de réaction on lisait
la tunisie la tunisie occupé pour
l'heure à sortir d'une crise politique
majeure ce matin lors d'une conférence
de presse conjointe quatre parties ont à
nouveau appelé le président kaïs saïd à
ouvrir le dialogue et respecter la
constitution de 2014 à qui
démocratiquement par de la crise pardon
démocratiques de la révolution 2011 ont
fait le point avec notre correspondant à
tunis ben hassen chébili
le président de la république doit
recouvrer la raison est respectée les
acquis de la révolution de 2011 et notre
constitution de 2014 c'est par ces mots
que ghazi chaouachi président du parti
le courant démocrate a commencé son
discours devant un parterre de
journalistes tunisiens et étrangers
quatre partis d'opposition ont organisé
ce matin une conférence de presse
conjointe pour fustiger les mesures
exceptionnelles annoncées par le chef de
l'état lors de son discours de sidi
bouzid le 22 septembre dernier kyles
iedge avait dévoilé les contours de sa
feuille de route tant attendu depuis son
coup de force du 25 juillet annonçant
entre autres la prolongation des mesures
d'exception et le gel du parlement pour
une durée indéterminée tout en abrogeant
le parti de la constitution tunisienne
des dispositions exceptionnelles
concentrant les pouvoirs exécutif et
législatif entre les seules mains du
président de la république pour
l'opposition une telle violation de la
constitution représente un danger pour
la démocratie
il appelle le chef de l'état au dialogue
national seule issue à une sortie de
crise qui doit selon eux être réglé avec
toutes les forces politiques du pays
sans ingérence étrangère référence aux
visites des 4 et 10 septembre dernier à
tunis deux délégations américaine et
européennes écouter
le message que nous adressons au
président de la république et que la
tunisie est dans une situation de crise
sans précédent et nous craignons de
perdre les acquis démocratiques nous a
permis la révolution nous sommes dans
une optique de réconciliation afin de
soigner la politique tunisienne rongé
par la gangrène et les défaites à
répétition
monsieur le président de la république
vous n'avez pas le droit de gouverner
seul de concentrer tous les pouvoirs
entre vos mains et de suspendre la
constitution
c'est un vrai problème quand le chef de
l'état ferme les portes du palais de
carthage aux forces politiques aux
personnalités tunisiennes tout en
rampant le dialogue et de l'autre côté
les ouvrir aux diplomates étrangers pour
discuter avec eux des problèmes
politiques de notre pays cette crise
doit être gérée en interne entre
tunisiens
même son cloche pour les leaders des
partis est à cape town et afek tounes
qui craignent une dérive autoritaire du
pouvoir et un enlisement de la crise
politique et économique pour fadhel
abdelkéfi chef du parti afek tounes et
ancien ministre des finances la crise
politique que traverse la tunisie a
entraîné une dégradation de la situation
économique dans le pays et coûté un
homme politique doit être capable de
donner des solutions pratiques à sa
population aujourd'hui il ya eu
certainement une dégradation extrêmement
grave de la situation des finances
publiques je vous donne juste un chiffre
la tunisie a quintuplé sa dette en dix
ans la crise libanaise a été déclenchée
par une crise tout d'abord politique
pendant des mois et des mois on a eu du
mal à former des gouvernements à
installer un chef du gouvernement
aujourd'hui la tunisie
et incontestablement dans une situation
de très grande fragilité des finances
publiques à côté il ya très peu
d'investissements privés et nous sommes
nous pouvons être dans le scénario
libanais surtout après toutes les
dégradations que nous avons eu des
principales agences de notation dans le
monde depuis l'allocution présidentielle
du 20 septembre dernier de plus en plus
de partis politiques ont dénoncé
l'abrogation d'un pan de la constitution
par le chef de l'état mettant en garde
contre le retour à la tyrannie sans pour
l'heure être parvenu à infléchir la
position de kaïs ayed qui continue de
faire cavalier seul faisant fi de toute
critique et appelle au dialogue dans la
tente de nouvelles déclarations carthage
annoncé que le chef de l'état se
chargera de l'élaboration de projets
d'amendements relatifs aux réformes
constitutionnelles
avec l'aide d'une commission créée aussi
par décret présidentiel
après la trahison australienne dans la
sphère des sous-marins la france
retrouve un peu le sourire les commandes
à l'export repartent pour un aval groupe
à paris y vient de vendre trois frégates
à athènes un marché conclu ce matin
entre le premier ministre grec et le
président emmanuel macron l'occasion
pour les deux hommes de mettre en avant
la dimension stratégique européenne de
ce partenariat antoine auger
des sourires une empoignade franche et
amicale les relations entre le président
français et le premier ministre grec
était au beau fixe ce matin à l'elysée
après la signature d'un contrat de 3
milliards d'euros pour la vente de
frégates françaises à la grèce une
alliance militaire qui vise à renforcer
la souveraineté de l'europe et qui
permet d'envoyer un message clair aux
autres grandes puissances
les européens doivent sortir de la
naïveté
lorsque nous sommes sous l'effet de
pressions
de puissance qui parfois se durcissent
réagir
montrer que nous avons avec nous aussi
la puissance et la capacité à nous
défendre n'est pas céder à l' escalade
c'est simplement nous faire respecter le
discours d' emmanuel macron a été
clairement appuyé par le premier
ministre grec qui n'exclut pas l'idée de
s'émanciper de l'otan et européen qui
est aimée pour aller chercher
l'europe à l'obligation d'avoir la
capacité de défendre demain hier
indépendante ses propres intérêts
nationaux géographique transeuropéen et
c'est quelque chose qu'elle ne peut
faire que si elle développe la capacité
de pouvoir opérer sans nécessairement
anticipées si elle le juge nécessaire
la contribution de l'otan ou des nations
une
île tout repos
car si les deux pays ont son ombre
l'alliance atlantique a été ébranlée
après la crise diplomatique des sous
marins qui a opposé la france à ses
alliés australiens et américains
du côté des manuels macron la tension ne
sont ne pas être redescendue
mais nous sommes obligés de constater
que depuis maintenant un peu plus de dix
ans les états unis d'amérique et d'abord
se concentre beaucoup sur eux mêmes et
ont des intérêts stratégiques que sir
oriente vers la chine et le pacifique
c'est leur droit c'est leur propre
souveraineté et je respecte la
souveraineté des peuples mais nous
serions là aussi naïf plutôt nous
commettrions une terrible erreur à ne
pas vouloir en tirer toutes les
conséquences et le constater pour nous
mêmes et donc là aussi c'est avec le
même pragmatisme la même lucidité pour
notre indépendance que nous devons en
tant qu'européens prendre notre part
dans notre propre protection dans sa
politique d'armement la grèce avait déjà
lancé un appel d'offres à la france en
2020 dans le but de contrer les
agissements turcs notamment en mer
méditerranée un appel qui se concrétise
aujourd'hui et que la ministre des
armées florence parly a d'ores et déjà
qualifiée d' annonce historique pour
l'europe
les directions à présent les états unis
où les plus hauts responsables
militaires sont auditionnés devant le
sénat et sont entendus justement sur
leur très chaotique des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan
on retrouve notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet bonsoir tomates
peut-on retenir de ces auditions genre
eh bien ce sont des auditions très dense
qui se sont déroulées toute la matinée
et qui viennent de reprendre cet après
midi ici aux etats-unis avec une
deuxième salve de questions de la part
de ces sénateurs qui forment la
commission sénatoriale des affaires
militaires aux etats-unis leurs trois
personnes sont entendues il ya le
secrétaire américain à la défense lloyd
austin et autour de lui deux généraux le
général marc miley qui est le chef
d'état-major aux états unis et le
général kenneth mckenzie qui lui est le
patron du commandement central de
l'armée américaine alors ils ont d'abord
souligner le succès logistique de
l'opération d'évacuation en afghanistan
mais ils ont aussi appelé à tirer toutes
les leçons et face à eux donc beaucoup
de critiques de la part de ces sénateurs
notamment des sénateurs républicains et
pour vous donner une idée de
l'atmosphère qui règne dans cette salle
d'audition l'un des sénateurs lorsqu'il
a pris la parole pour les cinq minutes
qui lui sont accordées il avait avec lui
une grande pancarte sur laquelle il
avait fait agrandir la une du magazine
the economist et sur laquelle on pouvait
lire la débâcle de bail dun voilà qui
donne le ton de ces auditions donc
beaucoup critiquent ont été exprimées
par ces sénateurs notamment sur le
manque d'anticipation qui a mené à la
situation chaotique en afghanistan ou
encore sur le fait que treize soldats
américains ont été tués le 26 août
dernier dans un attentat à proximité de
l'aéroport de kaboul sur le fait aussi
qu'il y ait toujours des américains qui
sont en afghanistan et qui n'ont pas
encore pu être évacués ou enfin sur la
composition pour le moins polémique du
gouvernement par les talibans alors il
ya aussi la question de la crédibilité
des états unis aux yeux du monde après
ce qui est considéré par beaucoup de
personnes notamment au sein de cette
audition comme un véritable fiasco alors
pour vous donner un autre aperçu à des
échanges parfois un peu tendu qui ont
lieu lors de cette audition il faut
revenir sur deux versions qui s'opposent
puisque joe biden au mois d'août dernier
et avait affirmé qu'aucun conseiller
militaire ne lui avais conseillé
justement de laisser des troupes par
exemple de 1500 soldats américains en
afghanistan au delà de la date du 31
août et bien cette version a été quelque
peu contredite par les généraux lors de
cette audition ce que n'a pas manqué de
relever un sénateur républicain tom
cotonne en l'occurrence écouter cet
échange
dans une interview le mois dernier le
président biden a déclaré qu'aucun
responsable militaire ne lui a conseillé
de laisser un petit effectif en
afghanistan est ce vrai
les données ont été reçues et examinées
par le président c'est évident en ce qui
concerne ce qu'ils ont spécifiquement
recommandé comme je l'avais déjà dit ils
ne vont pas révéler ce qu'ils
recommandent confidentiellement au
président
je trouve ça choquant cela veut dire que
potentiellement le meilleur conseil
militaire n'a jamais été présenté en
personne au président des états unis sur
un sujet si cruciale
vous avez entendu le secrétaire
américain à la défense lloyd austin qui
bottent en touche en quelque sorte mais
la polémique est en train d'enfler ici
aux etats unis puisque certains estiment
donc que des généraux ont pu être
ignorée dans la décision prise par le
président américain l'été dernier au
point même que la porte parole de la
maison blanche qui donne son
traditionnel point presse à la
mi-journée a été interrogé ça a été la
première question qui lui a été posée à
les revenus donc sur les déclarations de
joe biden du mois d'août en faisant donc
la comparaison avec celle des généraux
pour expliquer qu'il n'y avait pas
véritablement le sujet mais je peux vous
dire que la polémique elle est bien
réelle aux états unis et puis un autre
sujet aussi qui s'est invitée lors de
ses auditions au sénat puisque le
général marc mulet le chef d'état major
des armées est au coeur lui d'une autre
polémique puisque dans un livre qui
s'appelle péril et qui est paru il ya
quelques semaines ici aux etats-unis
bien les auteurs affirment que ce
général ce chef d'état major qui était
déjà en poste à l'époque où donald trump
était président avait à l'automne
dernier échangés par téléphone avec son
homologue chinois pour le rassurer sur
le comportement de donald trump en
affirmant par exemple qu'il la
préviendrait si le locataire de la
maison blanche décidé de la moindre
attaque contre pékin alors il est revenu
sur ce sujet il a devancé les questions
parce que vous l'imaginez beaucoup de
sénateurs l'attendait au tournant pour
l'interroger à ce sujet il a donc
devancé toutes ces questions d'abord en
confirmant que ces échanges
téléphoniques avec son homologue chinois
avait bel et bien eu lieu et puis
surtout pour donner ses explications
écoutez le
je sais je suis certain que le président
trump n'avait pas l'intention d'attaquer
les chinois et c'est ma responsabilité
directe et c'était ma responsabilité
directe au nom du ministre de faire
connaître cette intention au chinois
ma mission à ce moment là était la
désescalade mon message était encore une
fois cohérent rester calme stable et
procéder à une désescalade
nous n'allons pas vous attaquez
à aucun moment je n'ai tentait de
changer ou d'influencer le processus
d'usurper l'autorité ou de m'insérer
dans la chaîne de commandement mais on
attend de moi on exige de moi que je
donne mon avis est que je veille à ce
que le président soit pleinement informé
sur les questions militaires
voilà donc pour cette journée marathon
d'audition pour donc le secrétaire
américain à la défense ainsi que ces
deux généraux ils seront entendus à
nouveau demain mais devant l'autre
chambres du congrès la chambre des
représentants il faut dire que les
américains ont véritablement nécessité
pour eux de comprendre c'est qu'il s'est
vraiment passé en afghanistan ce qui a
mené à ce fiasco et peut-être aussi et
bien de trouver les responsabilités et
l'ami lustration de l'importance qui est
accordée à ce dossier afghan et aux
conséquences qu'il peut avoir c'est que
ces auditions elles ont été retransmis
en direct toute la journée sur la quasi
totalité des chaînes d'information en
continue ici aux etats unis merci
beaucoup thomas bonnet en direct de
washington
les noms de la pop et les huées la de
timides avancées dans le dialogue entre
le pouvoir et l'opposition la troisième
session de discussions s'est achevé hier
à mexico des échanges censé aider à
résoudre la grave crise économique et
sociale que traverse le pays récit ni
françois xavier lambert
ce sont les trois hommes en charge de
relancer un dialogue dans l'impasse
entouré des représentants du
gouvernement vénézuélien et de
l'opposition le diplomate norvégien dag
ni länder annonce des progrès dans les
négociations entamées le 14 août dernier
dans la capitale mexicaine un dialogue
sous l'égide de la norvège de la russie
et des pays bas objectif parvenir à un
compromis entre un pouvoir vénézuélien
qui souhaite la levée des sanctions
internationales et une opposition
exigent des élections libres et
transparentes
il a été convenu de tenir immédiatement
plusieurs sessions de consultation avec
divers acteurs politiques et sociaux
nationaux et internationaux
afin de mettre en place un mécanisme de
consultation et de participation
efficace dans les meilleurs délais
cette avancée dans le dialogue avec
l'opposition a également été confirmée
par le président vénézuélien nicolás
maduro s'est exprimé à ce sujet à la
télévision publique
cette semaine nous avons surmonté
quelques mésaventures avec la norvège
nous avons tourné la page et il ya eu
une journée de travail en séance
plénière entre les neuf représentants de
l'opposition
et les neufs représentant
plénipotentiaire du gouvernement
constitutionnel du venezuela
les premières sessions du dialogue ont
permis d'aboutir à deux accords sur des
points mineurs un mécanisme de
financement des vaccins anti qu'ovide et
la reconnaissance de la souveraineté du
venezuela sur un territoire du anna
voisin revendiquer de longue date par
caracas mais l'enjeu majeur porte sur
l'organisation des scrutins la prochaine
élection présidentielle vénézuélienne
est prévue en 2024
dans quelques instants nous parlerons du
présidial a augmenté de 12,6 pour cent
en moyenne dans trois jours la facture
d'électricité qui pourraient aussi
grimper en 2022 et pour certains
politiques ces hausses à venir sont une
véritable bombe sociale à retardement à
retardement quel dispositif dead sont
sur la table du gouvernement réponse
dans quelques instants
[Musique]
le résultat d'un dieu peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
la france et d'autres pays du globe
doivent faire face à une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre comment expliquer ce phénomène
depuis tout temps vous avez eu un taux
de chômage important et puis en revanche
des demandes des entreprises pour
engager des gens et qui ne se
rencontraient pas parce que formation
insuffisante parce que
inadéquation entre les gens qui étaient
sur le marché du travail est ce que
cherchait les entreprises et à chaque
reprise économique on bute sur des
normes pénurie de main d'oeuvre si on
répond pas tout de suite avec la
concurrence il peut y avoir des
effondrements de certains pans de notre
activité c'est un phénomène sur lequel
il faut travailler sur le temps long
malheureusement le connaissez tous le
temps politique il n'est pas en temps
longs il les entend élections par
élections
[Musique]
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes mais ce qui nous alertent nous
c'est la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qu'ils aient accès
fléché sur le traitement de la maladie
soupçon diagnostic et le traitement et
non pas sur la prévention et emmènera un
système très curatif 1 c'est essentiel
d'avoir l'information pour pas subir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du public il
est clair pour tout le monde attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose dignité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose alors jean franck
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie d'avoir
invité
tu
[Musique]
à la veille d'un procès historique le
procès des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
comment vous l'avez abordé je crois que
les victimes attendent de pouvoir
témoigner une exigence de vérité une
exigence de justice nous allons les
accompagner du début de la crise jusqu'à
leur reconstruction dante est que ce
soit possible pour certaines on parle
beaucoup de l'accompagnement
psychologique mais il ya tout un champ
d'accompagnement autres et
l'indemnisation qui est extrêmement
importante pour ces personnes la
problématique va être quel prix va-t-on
assigné à la douleur quel prix vaut
votre fille quel prix votre père et
c'est impossible c'est un procès pour
les victimes c'est un procès également
pour la république il ne s'agit de rien
d'autre que de juger des hommes qui ont
commis un attentat sur le territoire qui
doivent être condamnés
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire on s'intéresse au pouvoir
d'achat des français lé prix d'énergie
ont flambé ces derniers mois et ce n'est
pas fini dans trois jours les tarifs
réglementés du gaz augmenteront de 12,6
pour cent en moyenne la facture
d'électricité pourrait aussi grimper en
2022 pour certains politiques ces
hausses à venir sont une bombe sociale à
retardement
alors sommes nous à l'aube d'une
nouvelle mobilisation à l'instar des
gilet jaune quel dispositif d'être sont
sur la table du gouvernement
le débat est ouvert
[Musique]
après plusieurs hausses successives cet
été les prix du gaz s'apprête donc à
bondir au 1er octobre une nouvelle qui
fait vivement réagir dans les rangs de
l'opposition
les détails avec nicolas petit
à quelques mois de la présidentielle
c'est une nouvelle qui tombe mal pour
emmanuel macron ce lundi le régulateur
de l'énergie a annoncé une hausse de
12,6 pour cent au 1er octobre des tarifs
réglementés du gaz appliqués par angie
une augmentation qui d'après le porte
parole du gouvernement s'explique par la
conjoncture actuelle
il y a aujourd'hui effectivement des
prix de l'énergie qui augmente en france
comme chez nos voisins du fait d'une
reprise économique très forte après les
mesures prises sur le pouvoir d'achat en
plus du chèque énergie qu on augmentait
de 100 euros pour 6 millions de ménages
ont réfléchi évidemment à d'autres
mesures notamment s'agissant du prix du
gaz après avoir annoncé récemment que
près de 6 millions de ménages modestes
bénéficierait d'un chèque exceptionnelle
de 100 euros en décembre le gouvernement
pourrait procéder à un lissage des
tarifs dès cet hiver pour chercher à
anticiper la baisse des prix qui devrait
avoir lieu à partir du printemps 2022
une décision qui pourrait peut-être un
peu étouffé les flammes causés par cette
flambée du gaz
rappel les insoumis réclame le blocage
des prix des produits de première
nécessité on pourrait aussi distribuer
les dividendes des actionnaires d' angie
au consommateur
ce qu'il y a de plus scandaleux dans les
augmentations folle des prix de
l'essence du gaz de l'électricité
c'est que grâce aux taxes et à la tva
sur les taxes plus les français étouffe
plus l'état s'enrichit ségolène royal
qui demande à baisser les taxes sur
l'énergie limiter les marges des
distributeurs et rétablir le tarif
social parle de son côté d'une bombe à
retardement plus violente que celle des
gilets jaunes en 2018 la hausse des prix
du carburant avait été le point de
départ du mouvement de protestation
et des prix de l'énergie qui flambe à
quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle sans compter l'inflation
qui s'emballe dossier miné pour
l'exécutif le pouvoir d'achat si
important pour les français dont les
candidats ont pourtant peine à s'emparer
contrairement à celui de l'immigration
décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
et vic nous pour en parler et lexie
poulain historia listé france sur ce
plateau et qui apparaît dans le mur
arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire
spécialiste de la communication
politique bonsoir mon benedetti merci
aussi être avec nous gaz électricité
essence tout augmente un an ce qui veut
dire que le pouvoir d'achat des français
va en prendre un sacré coup et ça tombe
mal forcément sept mois de la
présidentielle
notamment pour un emmanuel macron qui
voudraient peut-être un joli bien
peut-être arnaud benedetti se faire
réélire
oui alors la question du pouvoir d'achat
n'a jamais disparu de l'agenda politique
vous savez c'est une question qui
véritablement apparu dans les années 70
avec le premier choc pétrolier et les
conséquences de l'inflation ceci dit
c'est vrai que depuis maintenant la
rentrée et même avant la rentrée même
avant l'été les sujets qui étaient
lisons les sujets les plus débattus dans
l'espace politique c'était des sujets
que l'on qualifie de régalien la
sécurité notamment entre temps rendront
entre autres où la question la question
migratoire
on peut imaginer que de toute hâte de
toute façon que la cristallisation si
vous voulez ce qu'on appelle la
cristallisation des enjeux n'est pas
encore fait on est il faut le dire à la
fois très proche et très loin des
élections présidentielles on est très
proche en effet parce que tout
simplement on est en 5 da d'emmanuel
macron mais on sait très bien que
l'histoire le démontre que les enjeux
qui vont être les enjeux saillant qui
vont orienter le vote lors d'une
élection présidentielle se cristallisent
très très souvent dans les dents les
derniers mois ceci dit il ya une vraie
question avec la question du pouvoir
d'achat parce que tout simplement on a
là une série de hausses en rafale qui
viennent en tout cas c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire grever le budget des
plus démunis et en plus ce qu'on a
constaté c'est que quand on regarde les
sondages le bilan économique des manuels
macro est jugée de manière négative par
les majorité de françaises et de
français il y avait encore un sondage il
ya quelques jours qui a été publiée dans
les échos où 58% des français jugeaient
négativement la politique économique du
président macron donc on peut imaginer
que les oppositions quelle qu'elle soit
qu'elles soient de droite ou qu'elle
soit deux branches vont se saisir de cet
enjeu pour essayer d'enfoncer un coin
dans la défense et l'illustration du
bilan du président de la république par
lui-même vous venez justement entité un
sondage 11 ans et un autre ce sondage
opinionway il ya une dizaine de jours
justement sur le pouvoir d'achat en
particulier
regardez plus d'un français sur deux
estime que son pouvoir d'achat diminué
durant le quinquennat d'emmanuel macro
56% elle existe ça fait quand même du
monde ça risque fort de peser vous comme
l'a dit arnaud benedetti ça va se jouer
dans les dernières lignes droites mais
tout de même ça va devenir un boulet le
sparadrap du capitaine haddock
oui c'est quelque chose d'assez
important parce que emmanuel macron se
voulait le président du pouvoir d'achat
il dit d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il
avait supprimé lisf réduits de nombreux
impôts ou qui sont en train d'être
supprimées également mais on voit bien
que ça ne fonctionne pas alors il pourra
toujours se réfugier derrière la crise
due qu'au guide mais ça ne suffira pas
parce que derrière il y à une inflation
qu'on ne veut pas nommer
christine lagarde à la bce dit que l est
contrôlable cette infection qu'il ne
faut surtout pas changer continuer à
faire marcher la planche à billets
surtout pas augmenter les salaires parce
que ça éviterait la relance donc les
français se retrouvent avec des prix qui
augmentent et des salaires qui stagnent
que ce soit dans la fonction publique on
a gelé le point d'indicé on est obligé
même d'augmenter le smic tellement
l'inflation est hors de contrôle ça
faisait dix ans qu'on n'avait pas
augmenter automatiquement le smic de
cette façon-là en cours d'année
d'habitude c'est au 1er janvier donc il
ya un vrai problème de pouvoir d'achat
et puis même si enel macron sur son
petit nuage croyant qu'il est le
président du pouvoir d'achat il a aidé
les plus riches certes mais il ne voit
pas les nombreux français qui sont dans
les banques alimentaires qui n'arrive
pas à se nourrir qui n'arrivent pas à
joindre les deux bouts 10 millions de
français sous le seuil de pauvreté des
travailleurs pauvres on a vu cet échange
aujourd'hui entre elizabeth bornes
ministre du travail et une française qui
était à pôle emploi qui disait mais vous
vous rendez compte 800 euros pour un
travail comme celui là on ne peut pas
vivre avec 800 euros je sais pas où vous
habitez comment vous faites il ya un
déni total de la part de l'exécutif de
la paupérisation d'une grande partie de
nos concitoyens et ça ça va peser très
lourd parce que c'est vraiment un angle
mort de la politique des macros qui est
le président des riches ne lui en
déplaise à laurent gabrelle atteindre le
porte parole du gouvernement a annoncé
que l'exécutif allait justement annoncer
des mesures fin octobre un homme et
d'eti contrairement concrètement pardon
que peut faire le gouvernement le
gouvernement baisser la tva par exemple
écouter de toute façon ce qui je ne sais
pas les mesures économiques que décidera
de prendre le président de la république
mais on voit bien que la stratégie
politique qui est la sienne c'est de
tenir coûte que coûte et quoi qu'il en
coûte jusqu'à l'élection du mois d'avril
donc il ya pour lui un objectif qui est
complètement lié à cet enjeu électoral
donc il va essayer au maximum de dison
permettre de de laisser une soupape qui
puisse faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas
d'explosion sociale le risque pour
emmanuel macron finalement dans la
période que l'on rencontre c'est de se
trouver confrontées et vous l'avez dit
dans ce reportage à une crise sociale
tel qu'il l'a connu il
non deux ans avec le mouvement des gilet
jaune alors ce qui limite évidemment la
possibilité d'une crise de ce type c'est
que on est à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle et que on sait très bien
que c'est là que les choses vont se
dénouer sur le plan politique l'autre
aspect qui est important je partage que
dit alexis poulain sur en effet le poids
de 7,2 cette de cette difficulté liée à
la question du pouvoir d'achat le
problème c'est que hélas emmanuel macron
ce point de vue là une position avec la
tactique qu'il y ait à ce stade propice
est favorable c'est qu' il n'y a pas une
force politique et c'est bien le
problème qui apparaît en mesure
aujourd'hui à ce stade à l'heure où on
parle d'un carnet aux yeux d'une grande
partie de l'opinion publique et les
sondages le démontrent une alternative
qui soit une alternative
crédible en tout cas pour 10 ans mener
une autre politique assène emmanuel
macron emmanuel macron il se nourrit de
cette de cette faiblesse finalement d
opposition il est minoritaire
certainement aujourd'hui dans l'opinion
publique parce que tout simplement une
grande partie des français jugent qu'il
a failli dans son mandat mais il n'y a
pas une force politique une offre
politique qui s'impose véritablement
pour venir en tout cas encore une fois
il faut être très prudent parce qu'on
est très loin de l'échéance du mois de
10 mois d'avril en tout cas il n'y a pas
une force politique qui semble s'imposer
aujourd'hui pour venir le concurrencer
donc allez les candidats commencent à au
compte-gouttes un énoncé quelques
propositions on va les prendre un petit
peu dans l'ordre et dans le désordre
yannick jadot tient celui ci est la
vedette de la journée un désigné ce soir
comme le candidat à la présidentielle
chez les verts
il propose certaines mesures écoutez je
suis favorable à l'atp puis flottante au
module les taxes en fonction du prix des
carburants sur les marchés on a une
évolution qui va conduire à
l'augmentation des prix des carburants
il faut que cette augmentation ne se
fasse pas de manière violente parce que
ça a un impact très lourd sur le pouvoir
d'achat alors justement impact sur le
pouvoir d'achat yannick jadot qui
propose aussi un revenu citoyen de 600
euros par mois mais une augmentation
très forte des prix du carburant pas
génial ça pour le pouvoir d'achat
l'expliqué toujours les mêmes qui payent
malheureusement on a vu les gilet jaune
une crise qui a débuté sur justement
cette taxe verte sur le carburant donc
vouloir toujours taxer les mêmes ça ne
peut pas fonctionner il ya d'autres
façons de faire évidemment la transition
écologique on peut la faire mais pas au
prix de faire payer toujours les mêmes
parce qu'il est en plus la dette
qu'ovide qui s'ajoute à tout ça et
aujourd'hui tout va bien puisque
bruxelles a décidé de suspendre les
règles budgétaires donc on peut faire de
la dette et mener le maquereau et bruno
le maire ont le beau rôle ils peuvent
faire des chèques et des cadeaux mais
dans quelques mois ce sera tout à fait
différent le discours de bruxelles et le
discours d'ailleurs de peu importe qui
gagnera la présidentielle mais il va se
retrouver avec des finances publiques
cataclysmique catastrophique et là ce
sera très compliqué donc il y à des
mesures à faire moi ce qui m'inquiète
c'est qu'effectivement l'idée même de la
pauvreté est totalement enlever du champ
du débat politique il y en a qu'un qui
en parle c'est jean luc mélenchon
puisqu'il veut parle justement des
banques alimentaires un de ces français
qui vont donc alimentaire il ya une
interview demain je crois dans
libération et donc c'est vraiment ces
français là qui sont toujours les
oubliés finalement parce que on va
parler quoi d'identité on va parler du
maréchal pétain mais on s'en fiche est
ce qu'on veut savoir c'est comment on
fait pour vivre dignement avec son
travail et le travail il y en a t'il
assez on voit aujourd'hui que finalement
on va former les chômeurs mais il ya dix
fois plus de chômeurs que d'offres
d'emploi quasiment je vois pas pourquoi
en les formant on va créer des emplois
donc il ya vraiment à une équation
irréductible et le chômage tout comme la
limitation des salaires elle est tenue
imposée finalement pour éviter que
l'inflation n'explose donc on est dans
un système qui de toute façon est
compliquée et produits de la pauvreté or
les politiques aujourd'hui on fait le
choix politique de la pauvreté et rares
sont ceux qui veulent faire un enjeu de
société et pourtant c'est un enjeu de
société renommée des tirs d'accord avec
ce diagnostic de d'alexis poulain
sachant que voilà l'une des favorites
mais en tout cas celle que l'on voit
encore à ce jour au deuxième tour selon
les sondages propose elle de
nationaliser les autoroutes pour
diminuer les prix des péages et
privatisé
l'audiovisuel public pour supprimer la
redevance télé c'est un peu mince n'est
ce pas en termes de mesures contre pour
le pouvoir d'achat mais si vous voulez
je pense qu'en effet aujourd'hui à ce
stade encore une fois la question
économique la question sociale ne sont
pas rentrés dans l'agenda de cette
campagne électorale mais sa masse fermé
il ya un paramètre qui dont il faut
tenir compte pour bien comprendre aussi
la position des manuels macron sait qu
emmanuel macron il a une sociologie
électorale qui est une sociologie
électorale qui l'a élu aussi sur le
respect d'un certain nombre de règles
relatives à l'orthodoxie budgétaire et
de l'orthodoxie économique et qui a
demandé un certain nombre de réformes
auxquelles ailleurs il a donné droit
qu'il s'agisse de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage ou de celle du code
du travail par exemple mais il faut
aussi qu'ils puissent tenir cet
électorat qui est très soucieux en effet
du logiciel qui était le sien donc
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui il doit pour
en tout cas être un candidat crédible
aux yeux de sa base électorale malgré
tout tenir un discours qui est un
discours qui va apparaître un disque
comme un discours peu finalement enclin
à s'intéresser à la question sociale
c'est une réalité c'est une réalité
j'avais dire presque sociologique en ce
qui concerne emmanuel macron la vérité
c'est que aujourd'hui finalement la
remarque un gars qui serait la martégale
gagnant pour gagnante pour un candidat à
cette élection à la fois de bien
insister sur les questions de protection
parce que finalement le moment où nous
avons vécu c'est un moment où la
question de la protection est apparue au
grand jour qu'il s'agisse de la
protection économique de la protection
sociale de la protection en matière
régalienne de celle de sécurité et pour
l'aïe pour les biens et les personnes le
deuxième enjeu c'est la question de la
vie quotidienne c'est bien évidemment la
question du pouvoir d'achat et le
troisième enjeu pour un candidat à la
présidentielle c'est aussi un moment
donné de porter une vision d'une vision
de la france qui soit capable de
projeter le pays dans dans un avenir à
la fois proche et et à moyen terme
aujourd'hui force est de constater qu'on
a du mal à trouver une hausse nos
politiques qui incarnent ces trois
éléments mais là aussi encore une fois
ça va ça va ça va finir par eux par se
faire parce que tout simplement la
dynamique de la campagne va être oublié
va obliger les candidats à tenir un
narratif qui soit un peu plus porteur
que les débats auxquels nous assistons
en ce moment qui sont des débats quand
même assez déprimant il faut le dire
sinon il ya du pouvoir d'achat ciblés
pour les enseignants anne hidalgo
propose de doubler le salaire des
enseignants alors on se dit que c'est un
petit peu idéale est idyllique mais
est-ce qu'on va craindre de justement
lors de cette campagne de devoir cesser
promesses peut-être peu réaliste se
multiplient et alexis paul a hélas oui
faire une campagne présidentielle c'est
beaucoup de promesses très peu d'élus et
beaucoup de gens qui y croient à ses
promesses alors il ya des promesses qui
sont chiffrés qui parfois arriva à être
traduite en politique et puis il ya des
promesses qui sont là simplement pour
animer le débat faire des ballons
d'essai provoqué aussi on parle de
radicalité dans le discours politique
c'est une façon pour une social
démocrate comme un dédale god et
radicale de mettre ça sur la table il
n'y a rien de réaliste dans ce choix la
dent dans de choisir en plus les
professeurs si ce n'est de dire moi je
vais proposer quelque chose de cet ordre
là mais le débat il va effectivement
évolué il va être donc en plusieurs
phases aujourd'hui je crois qu'on est
dans une tour de chauffe avec des
candidats qui ne sont pas tous déclarés
avec des écuries qui n'ont pas choisi
encore leur champion donc ça va vraiment
commencer en janvier où on aura des
candidats qui auront une chance de
gagner qui auront un parti derrière eux
et là les millions d'euros qui seront
amassés pour faire la campagne pour être
utilisée pour le moment on est dans une
campagne low cost où on est en train
d'essayer
billets de voir où ça va et la question
du pouvoir d'achat elle ne va faire
qu'empirer avec ce prix du gaz ce prix
de l'électricité la question européenne
aussi la question de la concurrence on
nous avait promis que la concurrence
faisait baisser les prix c'est faux
l'europe qui protège elle protège de
quoi finalement c'est compliqué donc ces
débats là vont arriver plus tard et ce
seront sans doute des débats techniques
et qui demanderont des réponses
justement et des promesses chiffrées
concrètes et réalistes aujourd'hui on
peut raconter un peu n'importe quoi ce
sera plus le cas d'ici quelques semaines
on suivra également avec attention tous
ensemble merci beaucoup arnaud benedetti
lexsi boulin sur ce plateau merci
les licences provisoire des pêcheurs
français dans les eaux anglo-normandes
expire jeudi londres a vient d'octroyer
12 nouvelles licences la france en
devant des 87 supplémentaires paris
dénonce un nouveau refus des
britanniques de mettre en application
les conditions de l'accord du bric site
une pêche française ne doit pas être
prise en otage par les britanniques à
des fins politiques selon la ministre de
la mer de quoi mettre en colère les
pêcheurs français qui exige des
autorisations définitives
les précisions de martial peuvent y ont
ils sont exaspérés les pêcheurs français
de la manche hausse le ton dans deux
jours leur licence provisoire les
autorisant à pêcher dans les eaux
anglo-normandes va expirer le royaume
uni lui ne semble pas pressé de régler
la situation il y a un très mauvais jeu
un antijeu pour le dire ainsi
britannique
nous avons été patients nous avons
obtenu des résultats heureusement sur un
certain nombre de zones de pêche et de
licence mais on est loin du compte le
break site à redessiner les zones de
pêche en quatre parties autour du
royaume uni cette nouvelle répartition
entrée en vigueur le 1er janvier dernier
rend incertain l'avenir de nombreux
pêcheurs français le secteur qui fâchent
et celui des îles anglo-normandes où
chaque bateau doit justifier de 11 jours
de pêche effectuée entre le 1er février
2017 et le 30 janvier 2020 pour
conserver sa licence à jersey 169
détenteur d'une licence provisoire sont
encore en attente d'une autorisation
définitive
la date butoir est le 30 septembre mais
les autorités de jersey sont prêtes à la
reporter au 31 janvier prochain une
proposition inacceptable pour les
pêcheurs français qui témoignent de
leurs angoisses on a passé des mois à
réunir toutes les pièces justificatives
notamment pour les petits bateaux qui
n'ont pas de système de localisation
satellitaire on a tout donné c'est l'
angoisse pour les pêcheurs qui ne savent
pas s'ils peuvent réparer leurs bateaux
s'ils pourront payer leur crédit
les pêcheurs français réclament des
mesures de rétorsion du gouvernement
interdire aux bateaux anglais de
débarquer et réduire la coopération
économique ou universitaire avec les
îles anglo-normandes la france prévient
en l'absence d'un geste significatif des
britanniques la riposte de paris sera
proportionnel à l'offre de londres
et autre conséquence du break sifflement
deux chauffeurs routiers au royaume uni
qui est en train de des problèmes
d'approvisionnement de carburants est
depuis la semaine dernière les
automobilistes britanniques se re dans
les stations service le gouvernement
demande à son armée de se préparer à
prêter main-forte prochainement grégoire
douce et
des scènes qui se répète inlassablement
depuis plusieurs jours dans l'objectif
de réapprovisionner les stations essence
et mettre fin à ces files d'attentes
sans fin
le gouvernement britannique envisage de
recourir à son armée un nombre limité de
chauffeurs de camions-citerne militaires
doivent être prêts à intervenir et
déployés si nécessaire pour stabiliser
l'approvisionnement en carburant
outre-manche les automobilistes sont à
fleur de peau plusieurs heures sont
parfois nécessaires pour se procurer une
quantité réduite de carburant
n'ont fait là que vous êtes ici depuis
cinq minutes
non vous n'allez pas me passer devant si
vous pensez du fait que les gens ne
respectent pas la queue pas très british
n'est ce pas non ce n'est pas très
british mais vous savez quand il ya une
crise on est plus près tish n'est ce pas
c'est du chacun pour soi
les gens deviennent frustrés c'est juste
le rythme du trafic comment ça se passe
il devrait sans doute mettre du
personnel ici juste pour que ça continue
d'avancer cela évite que les gens
perdent leurs nerfs et cela permet de
fluidifier le trafic
je pense que toutes les règles partent
en fumée en ce moment les gens sont
désespérés si je n'ai pas d'essence
maintenant je ne peux plus travailler
aujourd'hui on en est réduit à ça j'ai
essayé d'avoir de l'essence tout le week
end il faut en trouver d'une manière ou
d'une autre on ne peut pas travailler
un ras-le-bol qui ne date pas d'hier
depuis plusieurs semaines les rayons des
supermarchés ont parfois eu aussi du mal
à se remplir pour expliquer c'est très
problématique pénurie deux principales
causes sont mises en avant
la pandémie et surtout le breakbeat qui
a entraîné une politique migratoire plus
stricte et par conséquent un manque de
main d'oeuvre dans des métiers souvent
délaissée par les travailleurs
britanniques
mais ce membre du gouvernement refuse de
blâmer le break site rien de tout cela
n'est dû au fait que nous avons quitté
l'union européenne en la quittant nous
avons repris le contrôle de
l'immigration nous avons la possibilité
comme nous l'avons annoncé d'introduire
des régimes de visas court terme mais je
pense que le plus grand facteur dans
tout cela est le vide pour pallier
l'urgence l'exécutif va accorder jusqu'à
dix mille 500 visas de travail dont
environ la moitié concernera le
transport de marchandises londres qui
annonce également dépêché des membres du
ministère de la défense pour accélérer
les formations de chauffeurs routiers
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis leicester au royaume uni avec
alister jones professeur associé
politique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir alister jones merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france boris
johnson qui envisage donc de
réquisitionner un l'armée pour acheminer
des sens vers les stations service et
ainsi faire face au manque de chauffeurs
on parle de la pandémie on parle du
break si t'as quoi précisément est dû ce
manque selon vous
c'est à dire c'est qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment eu de pénurie des singes nous
avons beaucoup skags séance au royaume
uni mais on n'arrive pas à la cheville
et jusqu'aux stations service nous avons
eu pénurie de travailleurs
l'approvisionnement
c'est de là que vient la pénurie
aujourd'hui elle a évoqué
la pénurie d'essence et c'est cet
article qui a causé à des achats
paniques et le gouvernement avait beau
dire il faut pas paniquer il ya beaucoup
de chance cela n'a fait qu'exacerber la
situation car les gens ne font pas
confiance aux politiques en ce moment
donc le la pénurie est de chauffeur
routier est dû entre autres choses aux
libres exit mai date mène la danse mais
je ne forme pas assez de producteurs
auraient unis et les conditions de
travail elles sont
très basses très mauvaise au royaume uni
on comprend que ce n'est pas que du au
break site mais c'est tout de même
une des conséquences clamant
tout à fait
estime
que 20 minutes chauffeur européens sont
retournés dans leur pays d'origine à
l'époque du président et ils n'ont pas
été remplacés le gouvernement essaye que
les faire revenir au royaume uni avec
des visas à court terme pour noël
les états membres de l'union européenne
disait que très peu de chauffeurs sont
intéressés car ils ont de meilleures
options ailleurs au royaume aux états
unis eau un oignon européenne
donc pour régional des landes à l'armée
de se tenir prête en cas de besoin
cependant le gouvernement a déclaré
aujourd'hui que l'approvisionnement a
recommencé et que le niveau de panique
réduit
mais sur le terrain la réalité semble
différente à leicester jones comment
réagit justement la population
britannique puisque vous mais nous
décrire l'une de ses premières
conséquences du du break site est ce que
certains britanniques commencent à
déchanter où ils prennent ça finalement
avec
relativité ce qu'ils auront malgré tout
qu'il va falloir s'organiser
au mieux le coup c'est une excellente
question
certaines personnes qui étaient déjà
contrôleur exit sont encore plus fermes
dans leur idée le président cet étui en
train de choix qui considère que ce
n'est là qu'une petit commentaire les
partisans du président dadis qu'il ne
s'agit pas que du président que c'est un
problème à lucerne
les conditions de l'emploi des
chauffeurs routiers que les salaires
très bas sont des facteurs majeurs
mais certaines personnes ne sont plus
aussi
expressive dans leur soutien du
président elles n'ont pas changé d'avis
mais elle ne proclame est plus les
bienfaits viserait que je sais car
l'épreuve semble indiquer le contraire
english
ces deux inspecteurs anglaise à moins
que britannique
nous n'apprécions pas forcément la
situation mais il faut l'accepter la
gérer autant que l'on peut il y
aurait-il d'autres conséquences
fâcheuses à craindre de ce break sitôt
au royaume uni
ça fait des jours et c'est cela une fois
de plus sera causée par le manque de
chauffeurs de poids lourds
sont étagères sont vides dans les
supermarchés
certains supermarchés
élargissent leurs allées afin qu'on ne
se rend pas compte qu'il ya moins à
d'étagères
nous savons bien d'autres problèmes avec
le conducteur il ya également par
exemple le prix du gaz nous avons des
pénuries de gaz carbonique et un le co2
l'utilisent pour étourdir les animaux
avant de les tuer pour beaucoup d'autres
choses
ce sont des conséquences du président
mais également de la pandémie et de
nombreux autres facteurs donc nous
trouvons dans une conjoncture toute
particulière
et sans doute que noël ne sera pas aussi
heureux que certains s'y attendent il
reste encore trois mois avant sans
essayer de résoudre la situation mais
pour certains problèmes il faudra bien
plus de temps que cela en espérant que
les britanniques puissent être fournis
en dinde à noël n'est ce pas à leicester
johnson merci je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur associé de politique
et c'est la fin de cette émission rendez
vous demain à 20 heures pour un nouveau
numéro en attendant l'actualité continue
toute la soirée en direct sur rt france
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
oh